vamos a conectar los interruptores a los
motores y para hacer esto vamos primero
a tomar el cable azul entonces vamos a
tomar el cable azul y le vamos a cortar
un poco del aislamiento y vamos a
atravesar el cable por el interruptor
así que ahí quedó y ahora vamos a tomar
las pinzas de punta y vamos a hacer un
doblez aquí entonces hacemos un doblez
aquí y ahí está perfecto ahora que sigue
vamos a tomar el otro extremo del cable
azul y vamos a hacer que atraviese esta
parte de del motor entonces para hacer
esto hacemos lo siguiente tomamos el
cable azul y vamos a cortar este pedazo
y después tomamos nuestro pela cable y
cortamos ese aislamiento de ese extremo
entonces ahora vamos a atravesarlo
hagamos que el cable azul atraviese esta
parte del motor justo así
y no no queda bien esto pero a ver ahí
está
entonces algún pequeño doblez para
asegurarlo
muy bien ahí lo tienes siguiente paso
hacemos exactamente lo mismo pero del
otro lado
así que tomamos el cautín y vamos a
calentar las conexiones que hemos hecho
entonces tomamos esta útil y vamos a
soldar
asegúrate de que la soldadura cubra toda
la conexión perfectamente aquí tenemos
otra conexión vamos a soldar esta parte
también todo lo que conectamos vamos a
soldar lo
así que ya tenemos todas las conexiones
y ahora vamos a revisar los
interruptores vamos a revisar aquí las
palancas
muy bien funcionan y bueno lo que sucede
es que debes tener cuidado porque si el
cautín toca por mucho tiempo el
interruptor lo puede arruinar porque lo
puede sobrecalentar entonces bueno vamos
a asegurarnos de que eso no esté pasando
que el interruptor esté todavía bien y
si lo está
y bueno bueno ya ya tenemos nuestros
motores están en su lugar ahora vamos a
dar vamos a hacer la siguiente conexión
y para esta conexión vamos a usar un
cable verde baja vamos a asignarle el
cable verde a esta siguiente conexión y
vamos a conectar los motores entonces
al cable verde le cortamos el
aislamiento de un extremo y vamos a
pasar el cable verde por este agujero de
este motor
y hacemos un doblez y después para
conectarlo con el otro motor vamos a
dejar un poco más largo de lo normal el
cable verde porque más adelante le vamos
a dar otro cable al cable verde entonces
cortamos aquí el cable verde dejándolo
un poco más largo y también vamos a
tomar el pela el pela cable y le
quitamos el aislamiento de este extremo
y vamos a vamos a atravesarlo por el
motor y bueno como puedes ver aquí queda
bastante cable extra
entonces el cable verde ya está listo y
bueno qué es lo que sigue sigue soldar
pero antes vamos a hacer una conexión
vamos a tomar un cable amarillo
y vamos a conectar este cable amarillo
con el cable verde entonces aquí está el
cable amarillo vamos a conectarlo con el
cable verde vamos a tomar el pela cable
vamos a cortar este extremo del
aislamiento más o menos que quede que
queden dos pulgadas y después vamos a
entrelazar estos dos cables entonces
entrelazamos estos dos cables así y ya
que hemos hecho eso bueno ves que queda
bastante exceso así que cortamos el
exceso tomo las pinzas cortamos el
exceso y bueno ya queda súper bien ahora
para qué es este cable amarillo el cable
amarillo a esto lo vamos a conectar con
uno de estos interruptores del cual ya
doblamos uno de sus tiros porque
necesitamos que sea un interruptor de un
solo tiro y un solo polo así que bueno
ahí está hagamos la conexión ahora como
doble el tiro bueno fue fácil
simplemente tomas tus pinzas de punta y
con ellas tomas el tiro
y los dobles pero ahora dobla los que
están en los extremos no dobles los de
en medio porque los del medio eso los
vas a necesitar así que tomas las pinzas
de punta y haces el dobles así fácil muy
bien entonces bueno hagamos esta
conexión pero primero vamos a colocar el
interruptor en su lugar vamos a poner un
poco de pegamento caliente con un poco
de pegamento caliente en esta esquina
del estuche de baterías y bueno entonces
pegamos el interruptor pero asegúrate de
de pegar interruptor pero que no que el
pegamento no toque la palanca para que
bueno el interruptor pueda servir
adecuadamente y ni tampoco debe el
pegamento cubrir los polos ni los tiros
muy bien entonces bueno cortamos el
cable amarillo más o menos que quede así
de largo y ahora vamos a soldar las
conexiones que hicimos también voy a
doblar un poco este cable que
no doble ahí está entonces bueno ahí
quedó
toma el cautín y recuerda debes limpiar
la punta del cautín después vamos a
calentar con el cautín estos cables que
entre las amos y la soldadura va a fluir
directamente pues los cables están
calientes así que ten mucho cuidado y
bueno también vamos a soldar esta parte
esta parte del motor y el cable verde
ahí quedó bien ahora vamos con el cable
amarillo al cable amarillo le vamos a
cortar
un extremo del aislamiento que tiene
aquí
con las cables y ahora con el cable
amarillo vamos a formar vamos a doblarlo
y vamos a formar un pequeño lazo haremos
la figura de un pequeño lazo con el
extremo del cable amarillo
de hecho puedes usar las pinzas de punta
para ayudarte a crear ese lazo porque
puede ser un poco difícil pero ahí y
después vamos a colocarlo de esta forma
en el interruptor entonces bueno así lo
colocamos y debe quedarte exactamente
así observa muy bien entonces qué es lo
que sigue vamos a ver como puedes ver ya
tenemos estos cables en una posición a
veces tienden a moverse un poco no a
quedarse en su lugar pero bueno
esperemos que se quede en su lugar ahora
vamos a tomar el otro pedazo del cable
amarillo vamos a cortarle aquí del
extremo un pedazo del aislamiento con
con el pela cables y vamos a hacer lo
mismo vamos a formar un pequeño lazo y
vamos a ponérselo aquí al interruptor
entonces formamos el lazo y ahí quedó
ahora vamos a conectar esto al otro lado
pero bueno como puedes ver nuevamente el
interruptor se despegó pero bueno suele
pasar tiene remedio no pasa nada
entonces muy bien colocó aquí el lazo
del cable amarillo y cuando creo que es
el cable del pueblo del interruptor
puedes doblarlo con sus pinzas de punta
eso te ayudará a mantenerlo bien
sujetado
y algo importante es que estas dos
conexiones no deben tocarse ajá es es un
poco difícil lograr que no se toquen
pero si se puede conseguir entonces no
deben tocarse porque si se tocan te va a
ocasionar problemas con el interruptor
el interruptor no va a funcionar bien si
si estas dos conexiones se están tocando
así que no deben tocarse
asegúrate de eso y bueno ahí quedó
entonces ya no nos puede ser
o bueno se salió el cable pero tiene
remedio vamos a arreglar esto ahí quedó
ya perfecto ahí lo tienes entonces bueno
ya tenemos aquí el interruptor conectado
y puedo usar el tercer brazo para que me
apoye un poco con esto porque está un
poco difícil entonces uso aquí la pinza
de caimán ahora y no baja no puede ser
que estos cables no se quedan en su
lugar ya se salió este otro cable pero
lo arreglamos vamos a colocar aquí
enlazarlo con este polo del interruptor
ah y no con las pinzas
entonces ya tenemos una buena conexión y
ahora vamos a soldar
a poner soldaduras sobre las conexiones
sobre estos polos
como puedes ver
y la soldadura que estoy colocando en
cada uno de ellos no se está tocando
porque yo no quiero que esa conexión se
toque es importante como te lo dije que
no se toque para que el interruptor
funcione adecuadamente y bueno ahí lo
tienes ya está esto soldado y entonces
lo voy a quitar del tercer brazo así
debe quedar como observas aquí y bueno
las dos partes que soldamos no se tocan
la soldadura en cada cada parte que
soldamos queda completamente separada y
bueno entonces vamos a colocar aquí un
poco de silicón caliente colocamos aquí
un poco de silicón caliente y para que
quede mejor lo que haces es ya pusimos
el pegamento lo colocamos en su lugar y
vamos a presionar por arriba por arriba
del interruptor presionas hasta que
quede un poco ya seco también cuidado de
no quemarte con el silicón caliente no
te vayas a quemar los dedos muy bien ahí
está y ahora una vez que ya quedó todo
esto en su lugar tú puedes
colocar más pegamento caliente sobre
toda esta área para que todo se mantenga
en su lugar a todo tu trabajo quede bien
sujeto aquí todas las conexiones y el
interruptor se quede donde debe ir y
también que los cables amarillos no se
toquen